yeah so like you'll enjoy being with a  50 year old like exchanging conversation  but like you wouldn't like it wouldn't  be serious you know I mean like it would  just be kind of I don't know like  understanding them meeting them but not  like it would never be a long time yeah  maybe a little kiss here and yeah no I  feel like just just for the purpose of  the question but it's just purely for  the purpose of the question but I think  if it came to a commitment scenario  um a couple years above me at most  um but I'll probably look down as  opposed to up yeah I've heard of that's  just how I view dating like I view it as  something that like I'm always seeing if  you could vent my life like long term  because otherwise it's just gonna hurt  my feelings yeah I think that's  typically more of a female view yeah